a woman has gone viral because she has a
PHD and she took an IQ test next to some
guy that she thought was just a dumb
rubbe hillbilly and the dumb rubbe
hillbilly did better on the IQ test than
she did I'm 21 I'm a high school
graduate and I work in the Marine Corps
I'm 30 years old I have my PhD in cancer
biology and I work in a Biotech Industry
grad school I went to University of
South Carolina and undergrad I went to
University of Florida 1 2
3 four 5 6 to me I don't know PhD cancer
biology scientist I work in a biotech
company we make coid 19 testing kids
stuff like that and then six it has
nothing to do with your background I
don't think you really have the highest
EQ out of all of us Tyler he ranked less
for me personally because the way he
carries himself he was ranking
intelligence based on his point of view
and not taking in other people's point
of views so number one is Raymond number
two would be
Kaye number three would be Tyler and
number four would be sha number five is
Shawn and number six is
[Music]
Mia so the guy the big dumb rub idiot
guy who only has a high school education
he has a much higher IQ than the gal who
has all these degrees and she's a cancer
researcher whatever I am not surprised
by this one of the biggest
downsides to University expansion and to
credentialism is that it convinces
people that they're much smarter than
they are one of the big problems that
has happened at the universities is that
social engineers and political activists
took over in the 1960s and 70s and
insisted in the name of what we would
Now call inclusion equity and and
diversity that we had to lower the
standards at all of the
universities and people of all
backgrounds all racial backgrounds
geographical backgrounds many argued
that this was a bad idea is you were
going to destroy education for everyone
and for some kids they weren't even
going to be able to meet the new lower
standards and they were going to flunk
out there was going to be a mismatch
there but there's a there's another
downside to this which is that as as
college and University admissions
skyrocketed and all of a sudden I think
it was right around the time that I
graduated high school something like
70% of high school graduates went to
college an all-time high it's actually
gone down since
then one of the downsides to that is you
were going to persuade
people without any basis that they are
much smarter than they are whereas that
kid with the high school degree and
nothing else he he doesn't labor under
any of those delusions he has a good
dose of humility and he he's probably
right actually it's not just that he
underestimated his intelligence it's
that he's probably right most of us are
not that intelligent we don't you know I
I read books for a living in large part
and I still know basically nothing my
education is still relatively pretty
derel by many historical
standards but the problem is if you have
the PHD and you've got the all these
fancy accolades and however you were
able to acquire them you just think
you're so much smarter than you are and
that kind of hubris that Pride will
blind you and it will make you
look dumber than the dumbest person you
ever met on the street right now go to
pre-born
docomo wle yesterday I got to catch up
with my good friends from pre-born they
came to the offices I love their mission
they're great I know you do as well that
is why I'm really really thrilled to
partner with them on this show what does
pre-born do they help mothers and their
children in crisis pre-born is reaching
into the hearts of women by allowing
them to hear the hearts of their babies
and introducing them to their precious
little
lives this connection just hearing the
ultrasound doubles a baby's chance at
life every day pre-born network of
clinics rescues 200 babies lives we all
talk about how important it is to
protect life and to stop abortion they
do it every day 200 babies a day live
rather than be murdered because of
pre-born and you can help too your gift
of $28 for a free ultrasound goes
directly to women in need and pre-born
doesn't take any of that money they
independently fund raise for their team
and their administrative costs so every
cent that you give goes directly to the
mothers to saving babies lives I think
it's great all gifts are tax deductible
especially you know the end of the year
comes and you don't know where to you
want to give but you don't know these
guys are absolutely impeccable you know
your dollars are Going the Distance dial
pound 250 say keyword baby that's pound
250 keyword baby or you can donate
securely at preborn
docomo Wes pr.com
five Republican Florida state
legislators have just switched from
endorsing Ronda santis to endorsing
Donald Trump uh Trump this was a few
days ago Trump gained seven endorsements
from state
legislators uh this was the same day he
gave a speech at the Florida Freedom
Summit so two people who had not yet
endorsed endorsed Trump and then five
flipped the ones who flipped were state
reps Jessica Baker Webster Barnaby Alena
Garcia Kevin steel and state senator
Debbie Mayfield
now on the other side of that news cycle
the governor of Iowa Kim Reynolds Just
endorsed Ronda
santis so where does that leave the race
I think don't shoot the messenger you
know I love Ronda santis uh I think this
is just yet another sign the momentum is
with Trump
here Trump unveils these endorsements
why would someone who had previously
endorsed one candidate switch the reason
that they would do that is because they
believe what maybe they had a genuine
change of heart or more likely they
realized that the guy they backed is not
going to win and so they can they can
still get on the team that appears more
likely to win and maybe they'll be able
to receive some political favor as a
result of that and maybe this will help
with their re-election campaign they
could get some kind of appointment
that's what they're after now shortly
after that announcement DeSantis
formally uh announces that he's got the
endorsement of the governor of Iowa uh
the good for him maybe that'll swing
some boats Trump is still way up in Iowa
um in the polls and among committed Iowa
caucus goers so I don't know that it
that it moves a whole lot even if it
does Iowa hasn't predicted the
Republican nominee for president since
George W bush but in' 08 12
16 it hasn't so I'm not sure that that's
particularly uh persuasive now and
furthermore I I think DeSantis had to
pull the trigger on the the Kim Reynolds
endorsement which has been rumored for
weeks now because Nikki Haley is tied
with DeSantis in Iowa so even you know
the disantis campaign moves its people
to Iowa to say this is going to be our
big stand and this is where we're going
to take the momentum away from Trump but
even there Nikki Haley has come up and
she she's rivaling Dan santis for the
number two spot so I think DeSantis in a
way had to make the the Reynolds
announcement less to hurt Trump's
momentum and more to hurt Haley's
momentum over there why is all this
happening though why hasn't especially
if you're someone who loves Ronda santis
and you're backing his campaign or you
love Nikki haly or any of the other
candidates why is it the case that Trump
keeps doing so well I think there are a
lot of reasons for that but even in this
present news cycle I think the war in
the Middle East helps Trump and the war
in the Middle East helps Trump because
Trump unexpectedly to most brought peace
to the Middle East Trump had the best
Middle East policy of any president in
my entire
lifetime maybe the best best Middle East
policy of any
president probably better than
Reagan's maybe better I don't know I
don't even know how far back we would go
into the 20th century he had a great
Middle East policy the Abraham Accords
were a major victory the fact that he
destroyed Isis first of all then uh
basically seemed like a dove and didn't
want to go and launch new wars in the
Middle East but then would occasionally
drop the Moab or would occasionally
assassinate Iranian General and so that
unpredictability had people playing real
real polite that's why people are
looking and they're saying man Donald
Trump who we were told was crazy and
wild and a cowboy he had peace in the
Middle East when he was President Joe
Biden who we told was a return to normal
brought us war in the Middle East which
sadly is normal I guess was the same
arguments with Reagan Reagan's a cowboy
he's going to start World War III and
then what happens he was a major peace
president whose president help bring
about the end of the Cold War boy what a
great clip that was now hey hey hey hey
hey man ring that Bell subscribe to the
Micha YouTube channel we'll see you next
time